okay i want to start today with how to
research a news story
that you read on the internet i often
talk about media literacy critical
thinking epistemology understanding why
we believe the things we believe
and part of this as news consumers is is
what i'm reading trustworthy can i
believe what i'm reading so i'm going to
do this in kind of order of depth and
time so like this is the order you could
do it in and you could stop at any time
this is this is going to be a lot of
work is is the truth uh and it's not
realistic that every news consumer is
going to do this level of research on
every single story but the typical thing
that happens is we have an article the
article says something
um and we need to figure out can can we
trust it um and this is to be very clear
not how you would do academic research i
know some people will say dave david
this is not how academics research
academic topics no no i'm just saying
this is something the average news
consumer can do
if you want to at least have a framework
for figuring out can i believe what i'm
reading so
i deliberately picked an article from
the website raw story to start with i'm
not criticizing raw story i'm just using
raw story because it's an article that
is emblematic of so much of what there
is on the internet which is it's
basically a rewrite it's not a primary
source
this is an article based on another
article okay so let's start here and
we'll go and you you could stop anywhere
but this is the order i'd suggest
you're presented with an article the
article is from raw story and it says
new york lieutenant governor brian
benjamin arrested on federal bribery
charges okay now you start reading
through the article and you will realize
oh this is not original reporting this
is a rewrite of an original article
in this case it's really easy to tell
because the first line is the new york
times reported that new york lieutenant
governor brian benjamin has surrendered
to federal authorities on bribery
charges now you can finish reading this
article if you want or you could go
right to the primary source so we go to
the primary source which is the new york
times article great
so
you can read this article this would be
the next thing to do lieutenant governor
benjamin resigns following campaign
finance indictment
brian benjamin new york second in
command to the governor was charged with
bribery okay so you read this article
great
now one thing that is useful to do in
assessing media bias would be well this
is a new york times article
what's the deal with the new york times
we all
sort of know the new york times but
imagine that it's a less well-known
primary source but the fir the next
thing that you would do is you would
google
the name of the media outlet and the
word bias
or the word
source watch if there's a source watch
page that can be useful and you will
find websites that will assess the
credibility of the source in the case of
the new york times there's many
allsides.com will talk to you about the
new york times and it says the new york
times leans left
and it gives you information about how
that was determined and it tells you
different things about the new york
times the ad fontess media
page will have a page about the new york
times bias and reliability
source watch for some more prominent
media outlets
will tell you about what is the new york
times again new york times most of us
don't need to do this but you might come
across a source and you don't know if
it's credible so you would want to after
finding the primary source
learn a little bit about the media
outlet great
now sometimes
it's about the author of the article the
author themselves might be notable
in this case it's a group of authors
from the new york times william rashbaum
nicholas fandos and jeffrey mays
if bob woodward is the author
the author has a multi-decade history
and you can examine that to kind of
build your assessment of the of the
story
these are less well-known uh authors and
so just as an example
william rashbaum is not notable enough
to have his own wiki page but you can at
least look at the william rashbom page
on the new york times and it tells you
this is a senior writer metro staff he
does political and municipal corruption
so okay this is not like a culture
writer writing about political
corruption it's a political corruption
story and that's what this particular
journalist writes about
uh he used to cover federal courts in
brooklyn he was the newspaper's police
bureau chief great okay so we have a
bunch of information about william
rashbaum and he seems well suited based
on his experience to write about this
type of thing great okay so
we could stop here and we could say like
this is it the
this is a it's an author
who knows about this topic
in a generally reliable media outlet
we're comfortable okay
now
you could go further
this is an article about
uh federal bribery
so you could actually say well let me
look at the underlying law and cornell
has a great website
where you can look up any law and
statute and you can say let me learn
what is in the bribery of public
officials and witnesses
federal statute because that's what this
entire story is based on great well i
might also want to know the history of
such charges who else has been charged
with federal bribery who's been
convicted is there a political nature to
these types of charges so there's a wiki
page called
list of united states officials the list
of united states state officials
convicted of federal corruption charges
which includes bribery now you might say
well but david wikipedia is not a good
source
wikipedia is a great aggregation
when there are citations because you can
start looking through this list and you
see all these different people governor
rod blagojevich and many others and
there's citations for all of these you
can actually look at notes and if you
say oh okay well what was the deal with
rod blagojevich's conviction
so it's actually very very useful for
that
and then also you know it could be
useful again diving deeper to look at
information about the person that the
article is about this entire story is
about the lieutenant governor brian
benjamin so you might start with their
wiki page and again you're not using
wiki so much as a source
you're using it as a kind of clearing
house for citations and you could learn
about brian benjamin's history does he
have a history of legal trouble
uh
uh on and on okay so so you would go
from there you could find kind of key
information about the person in their
bio that's not in the article so this is
like
the minimum to really more deeply start
understanding a topic and knowing
whether remember we started with a
rewrite on raw story
and compare what you would know just
reading the raw story article versus
actually doing this work now this is
just a framework
imagine it's a science story well that's
arguably more complex imagine that we're
looking at an article about
um
anti-nuclear activists
are warning about building new nuclear
well okay that's a lot so is it the
original source or not we would want to
go to the primary source but nuclear
power is a major academic topic so we
might even go to scholar.google.com
and search for nuclear power nuclear
safety differences between 40-year-old
nuclear power and modern nuclear power
okay so so it takes work
and understandably most people don't
have time to do this level of
investigation
for every news story you get but it
should at least let you know that
reading a piece on raw story is not
going to leave you informed in a way
that i would like to be
if i'm going to be talking about a topic
keep in mind when the anti-vaxxers say
i've done my research
think about what research they may have
done and you can actually use this
framework to inquire and probe whether
they've really actually done their
research so hopefully this is useful
let me know maybe at some point i'll do
another example with you know i
deliberately picked a pretty cut and dry
story which just like a guy got arrested
and here's here's why
um
to show the depth you can go in even for
that uh if this is useful i'm glad to
glad to do it again with other topics
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video